welcome to Medford Massachusetts Duncan
Scenic Medford why travel when you're
already there that's our slogan you can
have a whatever you want for free I know
you've been Affleck brother
yeah I'm struggling I'm gonna smell oh
I'm so sorry I can't make it function
malfunction not as easy as it looks
operating this apparatus a bit medium
hot black uh we're out of uh coffee oh
you're out of coffee yeah we get no
coffee and no Donuts what do you got ah
water
I'm trying to compensate with comedy for
my ineptitude hey what can I do for you
Duncan run medium a large coffee get a
donut for an incremental dollar you
interested I'm just I'm gonna ask you to
please take the deal sir you need me
right now sir I want you to take the
Duncan run double sausage turkey sausage
egg and cheese maple sugar bacon black
peppercorn are you all right this time
I'm coming on Blue how are we doing all
right how's your mother good father all
right it's even better good all right
I'll see you around all right not your
typical Duncan technician usually a much
smarter again
[Music]